[Applause]
dr. Peterson you mentioned these ideas
of responsibility of virtue of respect
you didn't
detailed what you think students
shouldn't do in these examples of like
protests and these examples of certain
types of activist tactics what advice
would you have for students how can
students make the changes that they want
to make particularly do you have any
advice for students here yeah read great
books mm-hmm really then you've got this
four year period that has been carved
out of your lives by society they it's
given you an identity like a high
quality identity and freedom at the same
time and you're not going to get that
again in your life you've got a you've
got a respectable identity University
student and complete freedom associated
with that or as near as you're ever
going to get and you've got these
unbelievable libraries that are full of
the writings of people who are who are
intelligent and articulate beyond
comprehension and you know and and you
can go there and you can learn all this
and you might think well why should you
learn it well you learn it to get a job
or you learn it to get good grades or
you learn it to get a degree and that's
all nonsense it's nonsense
the reason that you come to university
to be educated is because there's
nothing more powerful than someone who
is articulate and who can think and
speak its power and I mean power of the
best sort its authority and influence
and respectability and competence and so
you come to University to craft your
highest skill and your highest skill is
to be found in articulated speech and if
you're if you're if you're a master at
formulating your arguments you win
everything and better than that
when you win everything everyone around
you wins too because to transform
yourself into let's consider you
consider your transformation to
something approximating the logos it
means you shine a light on the whole
world well there's nothing more exciting
to do than that there's nothing better
you can possibly do and to think that
you're coming to university to be you
know trained to have a job it's like
great that's a hell of a lot better than
being unemployed and covered with cheeto
dust while you're snacking away in front
of your video game in the basement but
it's not it's not a and I don't have
anything against video games by the way
but it's hardly a triumphant call to to
being in the world and that's what
university should be calling forth it's
like God you people you you know I know
what Harvard students are like I taught
here for five years you people are
spectacular you're spectacular you're
you're all capable of being world
beaters you transform yourself into
something that's articulated and
sensible and grounded in history and
knowledgeable and wise man you can do
anything you want and hopefully anything
you want for good because if you have
any sense everything you want to do
would be for the good because there's
nothing more compelling or meaningful or
or useful in combating the tragedy of
life than to than to struggle with all
your soul on behalf of the good and the
university hasn't forgotten that it's
why everyone's bailing out of the
humanities and they should the
humanities are corrupt and they're
correct because they're not telling
students this it's a bloody obvious it's
like learn to think learn to speak learn
to read it makes you a superpower an
individual superpower you have it and I
don't understand why that isn't just
told to students it's not that hard to
understand it everyone wants to hear
it's like really I could do that I can
do that like yeah really and could do
that and the whole society around you is
labored for really thousands of years to
provide every single one of you with
this spectacular opportunity that you
have while you're undergraduates and
graduate students here and that they're
just everyone's just praying that you
would come here and manifest everything
that you could manifest and that's what
you should be doing instead of waving
placards and complaining about how
you're oppressed for God's sake you see
these Yale students complaining about
their oppression it's just it just
leaves me a gasp it's like while we're
against the ruling class it's like no no
no your baby ruling class members you're
young
the only reason you're not rich is
because you're young you know that's the
best really this if you look at the 1%
even the dreaded 1% you know most of
those people are old why well when you
progress your life if you're reasonably
successful you trade in your promising
youth for your wealthy old age but
you're still bloody old when you trade
it would you trade your youth for that
like if you factor age out of the
economic equation things look a lot
different well of course older people
have more money if they have any sense
they've been collecting it for their
whole life is that somehow unfair it's
not unfair unless you want to want to be
poverty-stricken when you're 70 and you
don't want to be poorer strick
poverty-stricken when you're 70 so I
just don't understand what's happened to
the universities I can't believe that
you're not told when you come the first
day look man you are out you're here on
a heroic mission you're going to take
your capacity to articulate yourself to
levels that are under aimed of you're
going to come out of here unstoppable
you're going to be able to do anything
you want that's what you're here for
instead you're taught that well you know
the world is a pretty oppressive place
and you're probably at the bottom of the
victim pile and and and and there's and
there's there's virtually nothing you
could do about it except you know
deconstruct the patriarchy and it's so
we need and so pathetic that that
university should be embarrassed that
that's what they're peddling to students
I'm embarrassed by it you know I've gone
on public record telling parents what do
you well send your boys to trade school
because at least they'll learn something
useful and that's a terrible thing for
someone like me to say because I do
believe that the art that being
articulated and educated in the highest
possible manner is there's nothing
that's better for you and for society
and yry at the university is forgotten
this well that's postmodern Neel Marxism
for you you know now then the philosophy
of intense resentment and oppression and
group identity and God it's just
pathetic